salut il fait combien de métiers
différents
je suis juste capitaine dans l'année il
n'y a que deux récoltes et la danse tu a
un incroyable talent j'ai toujours adoré
danser depuis que je suis tout petit
c'est ma passion
maintenant que mon père n'est plus là il
faut que je travaille
et toi pourquoi tu es venu chez isabella
excellente question
j'en sais rien j'avais besoin d'un
changement dans ma vie pour me retrouver
savoir qui je suis mais noyé un peu de
la vie que je menais et je voulais aussi
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes
découvrir de nouveaux lieux si tu veux
je t'emmène visiter mon village dimanche
je pourrais passer le chercher à la
résidence vers 17 heures c'est un rendez
vous c'est en tout bien tout honneur
je me dis juste que je pourrai aider à
découvrir un endroit où tu trouvera
l'inspiration ou tu te sentiras bien
j'accepte en soit dimanche alors